One morning, an old water rat put his head out of his hole.
He could see a mother duck trying to teach her little ones how to stand on their heads in the water.
"Friendship is much more important than love."
"Nothing in the world is more important than a devoted friend."
"Let me tell you a story on the subject," said the bird.
"Once upon a time," said the bird,...
..."there was an honest and happy little man named Hans."
"Hans had many friends, but the most devoted friend of all was the miller."
The miller was so devoted to Hans...
...that he never went past his garden without picking some flowers and fruit from the trees.
Sometimes, however, Hans's other friends thought it strange...
...that the rich miller never gave little Hans anything in return.
During the spring, the summer, and the autumn, Hans worked in his garden and was very happy,...
...but when the winter came and he had no fruit or flowers to sell, he was often cold and hungry.
He was very lonely because the miller never came to see him then.
"There is no good reason for me to go and see Hans while there is snow on the ground,"...
...the miller used to say to his wife.
"But why can't we ask Hans to come here?" Asked the miller's youngest son.
"If he is unhappy, I will give him half of my food."
"What a silly boy you are!" Cried the miller.
"Also, if he came here, he might ask me to let him have some flour and that I could not do."
"Flour is one thing and friendship is another."
"As soon as the winter was over and there were flowers in Hans's garden again," the bird continued,...
..."the miller planned to visit little Hans."